this is the next stop on russia's war
path
a rocket slammed into this residential
street in the east ukrainian city of
slovyansk
at least three people were killed
it shattered our windows and shook the
building she says i'm planning to leave
to keeve russia is closing in on this
city just 12 kilometers from the front
line russian forces now on the cusp of
capturing luhansk and surrounding
ukrainian-held territory in donetsk the
two provinces make up the dawn bass
ukraine's industrial heartland and
russia's stated target if russian forces
do come to slavians these trenches will
be the last line of defense vladimir
putin has said since the beginning that
he's coming to liberate russian-speaking
communities in the donbass from what he
calls a ukrainian genocide but what we
have found talking to people here is
just the opposite ordinary civilians who
are digging trenches taking up arms and
preparing to fight
this gym teacher is now an officer in
the civil defense battalion
we hope our western partners will send
weapons to help us he says but even if
they don't we will do everything we can
to protect our home
air raid sirens now blare almost
non-stop in the neighboring city of
kramatorsk three-quarters of its two
hundred thousand residents have fled but
some can't albino vona morova lives
alone in this mostly abandoned blown-out
apartment building
i can't move i have no money she says i
grew up in russia there are brothers why
would they do this for those left behind
volunteers are providing food
before the war katarina onoshenka was a
lawyer i'm fighting
so
i stay here and i
fight for people's life a couple of
months ago she was handing out food at
this local train station 10 minutes
after she left an explosion it's
terrible sound she returned to find this
a russian cluster bomb hit the crowded
station 59 people were killed onoshenko
took this photo of the russian rocket
bearing the words for the children i
don't know why
for
what children they mean
what about
i don't know
for my children no i don't know the
mayor says many here used to be
pro-russian not anymore now it's not not
thinkable he told global news the war is
at a critical crossroads the next two
weeks are very important for ukraine it
will depend for us first of all how long
can we hold
this line the answer could determine the
fate of the donbass and perhaps even the
war
jeff temple global news sloviensk
[Music]